[Music]
so where are we then where are we
heading north of the border we're on the
road again we are going to the
canoe
it's an interesting place because they
use almost all of the produce from the
estate in which the restaurant is
located so some of the supply line
problems won't have hit them that's good
that makes sense it's a real
farm-to-fork operation they're aiming
for self-sufficiency and i don't think
they're far away from well i'm looking
forward to it this is
[Music]
james hi hi how are you doing nice to
see you good to see you hey james good
to meet you nice to meet you
so what do we got here james so this is
uh bow house which is uh we're we're on
the balcony estate
and uh and then just down the way here
is where we have all our uh
veg growers tom and connie and then uh
just literally down the road we've got
um some mornings and pitt and weem which
is uh that close yeah that close yeah
where uh we get all our fish and
shellfish and then in here is uh the
butchery okay so go check it out so i'll
leave the butchery to you guys maybe
i'll see you at the veg i'm vegetarian
of course
[Music]
oh wow this is big
so what have we got here this was just a
bit of falkor to me that i've been
chopping up so getting some stewing cuts
out of it uh getting some little steak
cuts out of it so this is quite a
underused steak called the petit tender
um but it's essentially like sort of
second most tender muscle next to a
fillet no one knows about it so it comes
out right from the middle of the
shoulder normally that sort of just
comes off as a big piece and it will
just get chopped up and put in trim or
whatever but if you just find this
little muscle and take it out so i'm
trying to get as many state cuts as i
can
out of each cow so using all these
different cuts which are traditionally
just thrown in with like stewing or just
intermittent and actually just trimming
them up to kind of give people more of a
choice i don't like to work in a kitchen
where you're just buying in like prime
cuts you know
and not just with uh
with cows like with sheep as well it's
kind of odd to just buy
like just solidly just racks of lamb and
stuff much more interesting for me and
much more interesting for the restaurant
and you're doing sheep and pigs here as
well yeah so
so sheep um the estate have sort of
different breeds which means they can
actually produce lamb all year round
because they they sort of lamb at
slightly different times and i'm also
doing quite a lot of mutton as well so
really getting the kind of coal used
that come from the estate um so we'll
tell you what the color you is so colu
is just a is just a sheep that's not
producing any lambs anymore so it's done
it's kind of working life i think you've
also got like as a butcher and as like a
chef you do have a responsibility to try
and educate people towards that you know
and we should be in kuluman not just
because i think it's ethical but because
it's delicious
[Music]
so we're on the estate yeah this is
where you get all the veg where we get
all the veg which is grown by connie and
how long have you been here connie um
we've been renting land from the estate
for
three this is our third growing season
it's a decent sized operation you've got
it two acres three polytunnels um it's a
no-dig system so you're getting 90-ish
percent of the vegetables yeah we got
the kitchen from here yeah we i mean we
use one other supplier which is over the
way and all the veg that we would say
was the blockbuster veg that can be the
star of the dish all comes from here
what difference does that make when
you're getting stuff so quickly from you
know sort of farm to fork it's more
important that we can get really high
quality veg if we get something that's
very high quality we
we don't want to mess around with it too
much so we won't be adding lots of
butter and purees we like to serve it as
it is so you can taste how how good it
is and hopefully
cook it with respect so we're hearing a
lot about the supply chain squeeze at
the moment does having access to
projects like this on your doorstep make
you resilient to that it makes us a lot
more resilient in uh in terms that we
don't really have to use like
large-scale suppliers or as much fruit
and veg as some places might use from
europe are you one of the lucky ones in
that respect though not everybody has
access like this um i i think if you're
going to have a a rural restaurant you
should be using sort of rural produce as
well that's that's grown out here
because it seems something crazy about
having a a restaurant in uh in fife and
then uh going sort of from london to
edinburgh you know via from milan in
that sense to get veg we work on a thing
where like they send me an email on on
like a monday and then they get the same
with luis who does the fish and i know
what there is meat wise as well so like
i'll see what's in season and then that
will govern uh what the menu is rather
than me say this is a menu i need this
i'll always be like what do you have
that's good right let's have that and
then let's decide what we're going to do
with it and for me that's just a more
fun exciting way to cook does that
hinder your chances of ever getting a
michelin star i mean i i don't know look
i imagine these uh chefs that do
work like that but it's not very
look a long time ago i decided that um i
hadn't a big interest in in awards and
stars what i had an interest in was
people sitting down enjoying food and
that gave me pleasure
[Music]
this is all local produce right and it's
an amazing selection of stuff oh that is
just a beauty these are razor clams
right they call these spoons
you're a lucky man yeah yeah i am
because we've got like the feds
literally like just down the road and
then we've got the meat
yeah and then
the fish here and it's that freshness
that quality that hopefully makes its
way onto the plate
[Music]
were you involved in the design of this
place so there was already a couple who
were sort of the architects who stopped
coming on board and doing the interiors
and then really when we came on board it
was sort of nine nine months before the
end of the project
and so i then would meet
with the architects because
there was a sort of whole idea of here
but also i just needs to come in and get
a bit more practical
yeah you know
for example the bar
didn't have that hole coming through had
to fight really really hard to get that
because they said no it doesn't really
work with the whole visual and i said
but this is so necessary but your
service flow is everything that's also
exactly there's two extra members of
staff to cover them yeah so just little
things like that but you know this was
it was really
built from the inside out you've ended
up with a easy utilitarianism yeah
there's a sort of sparsity but also yes
austere but but yeah comfortable i
wanted people to feel that you know
they're being welcomed into our into our
home as it were you know sort of with
the food and and the service and you
sort of feeling comfortable from the
minute you arrive
what are you doing here james yeah sorry
so these are the pork pies that we've
got on at the moment
in the restaurant so uh i'm just adding
the uh jelly which is traditional in a
pork pie i can't help but notice that
you're injecting this pie is that the
traditional technique no i i used to use
a jug and i've found it's a little bit
less messy to use the the sort of meat
injector and also quite apt at the
moment that it's getting vaccinated
right is it going to be double jabbed or
triple jump yeah it's getting like 20
times jab there's actually completely
immune from anything by the time it's
done
tell me about your your story james how
long were you working in london was it
uh sort of eighteen years working in
london
uh so i grew up in a restaurant which
was in uh halifax in yorkshire and then
uh i moved to london and this woman
angela hartnett was uh opening at the
connell and they needed chefs to be
there so i took a job there so after 18
years in london what led you up to this
corner of scotland well basically i was
asked to look at this place i bumped
into someone insured it she was looking
for a chef to take over here and she
offered me to come up they'd pay for us
to come up and have a look i said yes
and we came up and then when we saw the
produce and everything else was around
here we thought well
were you ever a bit concerned it was
sort of in a remote part of the country
yeah i mean i was concerned up to the
point when it you know
before we open and when we open anyone
who opens a business and especially
somewhere they don't know like an area
they don't know they tell you that
they're not concerned then i think
they should have been
[Music]
this place on the outside is it's like a
corner pub in a very very very small i
suppose village is the word for it yeah
how did how were you greeted when you
arrived what happened with the locals i
think it was difficult because obviously
this was a very old traditional pub um
which previously everything had been
traditional fair as they refer to it
so
it was quite tricky to sort of open and
people suddenly had been coming here for
20 30 years to suddenly come in and just
think what is going on here we opened at
the end of september 2019 and then
managed to get six months and we were
working incredibly hard and we're really
really busy
and then like everyone else we just fell
off a cliff we then
decided to do a sort of voluntary
service for the village so that we made
food at cost i think people really
appreciated that in the village and we
suddenly made
quite a lot of friends
so what happened then you brought some
some guys up from london to work
one of the guys that moved up with his
family and everything and then after
sort of three months of the pandemic he
decided to move back down and then the
other chef that was with me had been
with me from the start he didn't want to
be around anymore he wanted to be down
new yorkshire where he was originally
from staffing hasn't really sorted
itself out it's hard rurally but i think
it's a bit hard in like big cities like
london as well because i think some
people have had this time off with
furlough and
they've reassessed what they want to do
with their lives it's been more of a
struggle to get staff since uh
so it is one of the legacies of the
pandemic for the restaurant business do
you think gonna be the staff are gonna
have to be paid a little bit more
well i think it's already starting back
in the day like
uh when you started off you got paid
very little and you worked a lot of
hours and you was like well that just
accepted it then but i think
these days people just don't want to do
that and i can see why yeah
so you're opening up now back up to full
speed yeah are you finding staff
staffing is a problem you know we
are we're struggling uh to find you know
another chef to come on board
particularly where we are someone's got
to make a sort of
a life choice to come and be here if
they want to work in the kitchen it does
feel positive but i think it's about
attracting people to come and work for
us and and therefore we have to manage
expectations and also look at how we run
the business
and look at pricing and all of those
things and you know pricing needs to
perhaps go up and things need to so to
reflect
people's wages people's way of life it's
trying to find that balance
great food if you don't have great
service it's the two have to you know
they have to go hand in hand because
otherwise it doesn't work
[Music]
tim when james and althea came up here
in 2019 after sort of 18 years working
down in london it was already a bit of a
punch but then a few months later along
came covered and completely turned their
plans upside down it was definitely a
risk but strangely mitigated i mean they
were they were invited up here they were
recruited up here by the answer the
family who owned the estate up here and
there was a plan i think to try and
create a
a little bubble of food appreciation and
foodiness it hasn't been plain sailing
though they had to win hearts and minds
the locals didn't necessarily take to
them straight away extraordinarily
difficult but what's happening is it's
it's a double-edged story i i think that
they were helped to to set up they got
started comet hit covert immediately hit
them very very hard but also enabled
them to
forge relationships with the people
around them coming out of it they've
been partially insulated but they've
also used that time to be to become more
flexible in what they've thought about
to think more creatively and to
establish themselves something you know
with the food breeding here at the
moment is the kind of stuff you'd be
expecting from a place that has been
here 20 years it's it's it's confident
it's it's well thought out and it
mirrors the area around well speaking
about the squid on your plate is the
same squid that we saw freshly caught
yesterday so they're really making the
most of this amazing produce that's
right on their doorstep they're
protected from all these issues around
squeeze supply chains that we're seeing
and they've got some fantastic projects
which people might travel from far and
wide to come see it's a fascinating
all-around story different from other
combat stories we've seen but that's
been the most remarkable part about
going out and visiting businesses during
and after is it's it's not even just a
regional thing it's not just that
scotland has different cobia rules to
the uk it's far more than that it's by
postcode literally you know another
village two kilometers off that way will
have a totally different story
there really isn't a difficulty getting
people to come here and eat great food
what we're going to have to worry about
now is are there enough people to cook
it and to serve it
and will people pay enough money to
actually cover the increasing costs of
even the lovely producers here the price
of that is going to go up yeah there's
still so much uncertainty ahead but
as far as i'm concerned from where i'm
sitting
this is worth every penny
yeah i think you're right
you